[Music]
[Applause]
good evening
good to see each of you all it's good to
see y'all here here
my name is don jacobs welcome to the
table we are thrilled uh that you guys
are here
um just going to go over a couple of
quick announcements uh so tonight we are
doing our stay the table meeting so this
is kind of like a big i know yeah
this is kind of like like we only do
this like a couple times a year um so
this is our you know meeting that we do
where we talk about what's going on with
the table
uh you know things that you can possibly
potentially plug into
changes in leadership some of our goals
that we have for the year
um and just financial stuff you know all
the good stuff so we must definitely
want you to check this out stick around
it's tonight it's about seven excuse me
way too late
uh 6 15.
we want to be done by 7 15 we'll be
heading home so
right after this service so please stick
around
and then um put on the calendar
so good friday is going to be next month
it's going to be april the 15th so i'm
going to make sure i'm saying that right
yes
and we are going to be doing that in
partnership with pleasant valley um here
at seven o'clock so if you were at the
lent
service that was beautiful and it was
amazing and
first time i ever participated in
something like that it was very
meaningful so um
i love it when we get together and just
collaborate that way so please come and
check that as well i would love for you
to be part of that but then of course uh
today we are having you know actually
easter service um it's going to be the
it's going to be actually at 10 30 in
the morning
and we're going to be doing that and i
want to make sure i say this place
correctly uh blue is blue here in
events avenue that's actually here in
sac city
not too far
right up the road from here
so um so you kind of put that also
on your calendar 10 30
um that morning so with that being said
um one do a quick word of prayer and
then we'll get started with worship
lord just thank you so much for our
ability just to be here in this space
um thank you so much for just these
people um in this room and who can hear
hear the sound of my voice those of us
who are also in line um we are so
thankful that they are able to join us
um
thankful that we can stand
um here basically at the foot of the
cross for where you are
um
you know our weeks have been kind of
crazy
they can sometimes can take the mess out
of us
and we just don't always know what to do
with that but we know that we can come
here
check back in
refocus
and be able to just
be uplifted
with just knowing that you
love us
there we are
i'm so glad you guys are with us i can
just piggyback on what dawn just said i
got to go to the blue heron events
center today to check it out and
come for the llama is nothing else
i mean
you guys this place is unlike any other
you will want to be there all right
that's all i'll say it's all i'm gonna
say um why don't y'all stand with us
we're gonna get started
as usual your voice your presence your
engagement is wanted and welcome
this is not a performance it isn't all
play it's a chance for us as a community
to join in together
and speak truth um over ourselves over
our community
and to believe god for the more that he
has
so i hope you'll join in
[Music]
through every heartbreak
through every circumstance
i believe that you are my fortress
and you are my portion
[Music]
and you are my hiding place
i believe you are
the way
the truth
the light
i believe you are
the way
[Music]
the truth is
do every
[Music]
you are the one i love
the
[Music]
i'll truth
it's a new horizon
and i'm set on you
and you meet me here today
the mercies that i knew
[Music]
is
they can all come to
[Music]
of me
i believe you are
the way
the truth
[Music]
[Applause]
that are new
[Music]
the
way the truth
of me
[Music]
the truth
i
believe you are
i wanted to read this story out of mark
five
a woman who was there who had been
subject to bleeding
for 12 years
she had suffered a great deal under the
care of many doctors and it's been all
she had
yet instead of getting better she grew
worse
when she heard about jesus she came up
behind him in the crowd and touched him
because she thought if i just touch his
clothes
i'll be healed
immediately her bleeding stopped and she
felt in her body that she was free from
her suffering
at once jesus realized that power had
gone out from him so he turned around
him in the crowd and asked who touched
me
you see the people crowding against you
his disciples answered and yet you can
ask who touched you
but jesus kept looking around to see who
had done it
then the woman knowing what had happened
to her
came and fell at his feet
trembling with fear
and she told him the whole truth
he said to her
daughter
your faith has healed you
go in peace
be freed from your suffering
[Music]
i just want more
for you
lord i'm ready to open up my heart
to receive not in heart
but the fullness of who
you are lord i'm ready
i just want more
more of you god
more
[Music]
i just want
more of you god
more of you
[Music]
lord i'm ready
to
[Music]
lord i'm ready
i just want more
i just want
[Music]
more of you
i just want more
i
[Music]
just one touch
reach into
[Music]
from
i need more
[Music]
i want more
i just want
[Music]
i just more more
i just want
more of you guys
[Music]
i just want
want more
[Music]
i need more of you
i just want
more
[Music]
would you guys join me in the prayer of
the people and read this along with me
god for the city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all those
who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you lord we know that you
love us and that you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
roy
from online israel louis
sue spears
[Music]
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
is
standing next to me
there was
[Music]
there's another
either way
[Music]
set me free
oh
[Music]
as the darkness
nothing stands between us
us
[Music]
there
is jesus
[Music]
all the things
standing next to me
to be another
[Music]
battle
is
[Music]
nothing stands between us
nothing
[Music]
stands to me to be another in the
watershed
[Music]
cause i know that's where you'll be
i'll
[Music]
thank you that it's not just in the
moments where we're healed
that we find you with us
it's in the 12 years leading up to it
it's in the struggle
god that your steady hand of love
comfort
wisdom
healing
that we find you there each day
each moment
in our darkness
and god i'm so grateful
in moments like this where i can look
around and also see that you place us in
families you place us in communities
that hold up our arms when we're tired
that hold back the waves when they're
pressing in god
i'm so grateful for your goodness
and sometimes that looks like healing
and sometimes that looks like someone
crying beside me
sometimes it looks like the answer to my
prayer and sometimes it looks like other
people who won't give up on me even in
the midst of my struggle even in my
weaknesses
and that's how you are god
with us through the good and the bad
breaking through our darkness and
offering life offering light and hope
god would we grab on
to you would we reach out and cling even
to the edge of your robe
knowing that it's with you that we find
our peace
it's with you that we experience the
light
and wherever you are god that's where i
want to be
that's where we want to go god
so keep leading us and guiding us
help us to keep finding you along the
way
it's in your name i pray
amen
thank you guys for worshiping together
with us if y'all want to sit down and as
you do turn and greet the people around
you say hello and brett will get started
with our message
good evening everyone
grace and peace
it is uh so good to be with you all
welcome to the table and that uh of
course
yes includes all of you but especially
uh those joining us online
we love you a lot you are not forgotten
the extended table family and uh and
everyone who might be new here and kind
of just plugging in oh we're really
really glad that you're here we don't
want to be a uh
kind of an usborne and no more
kind of church you know sometimes
churches can get a little
a little bit like that and uh we we want
to be a hospitable
a communal people that's one of our
values here the tables to be communal so
um we're very glad that you're here so
we are in um kind of a season in the
church calendar there's kind of a whole
rhythm um that the church has been
really kind of practicing for thousands
of years and um and so we're in the
season known as lent and uh lent for
those unfamiliar is basically a kind of
a 40 day or roughly 40 day um time of
spiritual preparation as we approach um
good friday that is the day of the cross
and uh easter sunday so um we are kind
of like right in the middle-ish of that
you know that season so um i'm i'm this
has been a really um
i've talked to a number of you this has
been like your first time to engage the
season of lent and i think i think
that's really cool and i love that um
it really makes the season so much more
meaningful you know it's easy to like
when you don't engage lent like all of a
sudden before you know it it's like
easter sunday and it's like oh yeah yeah
he has risen you know it's almost like
uh like trying to watch a movie and just
skipping to the end and you're like yeah
and i mean there's something about the
journey there you know the journey to
the cross the journey through
um kind of the depths of um struggle on
holy saturday and then to enter into
easter sunday it's just it's just
beautiful so all that to say i'm really
uh grateful to be on this this path with
you all so um with that in mind we are
just kind of sticking to uh the the
prescribed um
uh scriptures for this series
so i'm following the united methodist uh
kind of lectionary so we're going
through um we've been in a lot in luke
and we're going to continue there
tonight next uh actually two weeks from
tonight we'll be into john um but for
tonight still in luke and so our text is
from luke chapter 13. um verses six
through nine the title of my message
is fig trees and fast food culture
it'll make sense later
all right reading verse six then jesus
told this parable
a man had a fig tree growing in his
vineyard
and he went to look for fruit on it but
did not find any
so he said to the man who took care of
the vineyard for three years now
i've been coming to look for fruit on
this fig tree
i haven't found any
cut it down
why should it use up the soil sir the
man replied
leave it alone for one more year
and i'll dig around it and i'll
fertilize it if it bears fruit next year
fine
if not then then
cut it down
okay
so that's it that's the whole story
and uh it might lead you in a place of
kind of wondering like huh so is this
like literally a story about
good
fig tree
cultivation practices
is that uh is that we're talking about
now um the answer to that would be no i
mean yes and no um
i primarily know though because if
you're familiar with
jesus and some of his teachings he he
loves this um kind of symbol or metaphor
of a fruit tree not just any tree but
specifically a fruit tree for a life a
human life
because
a fruit tree produces things
uh fruit
all right
and
uh
i love jesse and abby laughed at that i
like that they like get it like it was a
joke all right
um
then uh a life right a human life also
produces things
and all sorts of things right
relationships um successes failures
virtues vices you know it just produces
things um and so jesus he was really
fond of this this kind of metaphor so he
like for example there's a place in the
gospel matthew where he's talking to the
pharisees
who as we actually mentioned last week
they're kind of his often his religious
adversaries
and he says you need to you need to
produce fruit
in keeping in other words in alignment
with repentance
which can sound a little bit kind of
like way what does that mean but
basically he's just saying like the the
results of your life you keep you
pharisees you keep talking about repent
repent repentance this is what we need
you know and yet your own life the fruit
the results of your life it's not in
alignment with your message
right so he this so he uses that
metaphor produce fruit in keeping with
repentance
um another time actually just a few um
chapters seven chapters before this in
gospel luke he's looking to an audience
and uh teaching them and he says good
trees produce good fruit in bad trees
produce bad fruit you will know them by
their fruit
right and again he's not talking like
his point isn't like wow we're really
learning so much about trees you know
that's not it's not the point he's
talking about our life
right the what is the fruit what is the
the result of our life so um with that
kind of background in mind i think there
is very good reason to believe um that
when this this parable about the fig
tree this is a parable about our living
right the fig tree is the the fruit the
the results
um the the actions um relationships
successes failure all the things the um
the fruit of our lives so um
okay so this brings up the question uh
who is the vineyard owner
he seemed if you uh caught the parable
he was the guy cut it down
cut it down you know so like oh who
who's that guy um it's it's funny um or
not funny it's kind of sad often when we
uh
hear a parable or read a parallel jesus
and like
there's anyone in the parable who is um
authoritative
uh strict
maybe a little jerkish
we're like i knew that is that's god
that's the that's the heavenly father
our good heavenly father you know isn't
it strange how any time we read a verbal
like that it's just kind of okay well i
don't know a lot about this parable what
i do know is that's god you know um
it's interesting that's so uh if you're
here last week so fox-like
not not hin-like you know this is this
is about our image of god i think it
says that tells us a lot doesn't it
about our own just
assumptions when we come to the bible we
read the bible and it's like we're
interpreting it we don't even realize
we're interpreting the bible we just
we're just reading it for its plain
meaning
no
right we're
i mean everything back from our
first grade sunday school teacher you
know it's like all the ideas and
it's all back there you know
so um
all that to say um as we kind of come to
check check
test test
all right let me switch
red where's that red one over here cool
all right there we go always have a
backup
all right so um
okay so this we are still kind of have
to wrestle this question okay so who who
is it it's not god you know um
i i think one thing to keep in mind is
the uh the jesus's original audience uh
so keep in mind you know like for us as
modern people like we read a parable
like this or listen to it and we're just
like i have no idea what's going on i
don't are we supposed to feel outraged
maybe like three three yeah three years
i can't believe it three years you know
we don't really know like
but keep in mind um jeez original
audience they were um peasant farmers
vast majority of them so um i mean if
you've spent your life like just to make
it
growing things my hunch is like they're
not ignorant about fruit trees that's
just my guess so which is why i think he
gives it he's always using these kinds
of analogies and
metaphors because he knows it will
connect with his audience um
so here's what they weren't thinking
um when they heard this parable what
they were not thinking
was oh my god oh yeah three years you
say oh that's oh that's horrible i agree
cut it down cut that tree down that's
that's that's a bad fruit tree um
because fruit trees uh in fig trees in
particular
uh take anywhere from like three to
upwards of like five six if sometimes
even seven years to actually make fruit
and so they would have known this
um in other words when they were hearing
this parable um they weren't thinking oh
my that's forever um no actually quite
the opposite they were thinking wow
that's
so uh so soon you know so
so so quick there's uh in fact there's
even like a little teaching this is from
leviticus this little portion of the old
testament where god is like giving the
israelites instructions as they come
into the promised land about how to
cultivate fruit trees and uh
he says this when you enter the land and
plant any kind of fruit tree
regard its fruit has forbidden for three
years
you're to consider it forbidden it must
not be eaten now my hunch is for sure
jesus knew this passage probably a
number of the people in the audience
also knew um
and
so in other words when they're hearing a
parable about this vineyard owner who
shows up and like every year he's like
checking this thing like shaking it like
is there any come on it's been six
months what is this thing doing you know
like they're not thinking like oh yeah
that's awesome good good practice that's
not best practices like no like they're
they're thinking like no this is not
good
right he uh in the fourth year he says
verse 24 in the fourth year all its
fruit will be holy an offering of praise
to the lord in the fifth year you may
eat its fruit in this way your harvest
will be increased i am the lord your god
in other words um jesus original
audience they weren't sympathizing with
this vineyard owner
right they weren't thinking like yep
he's right on no they what the way this
parable likely struck them uh i want to
contend is that what they're hearing is
a a parable about a an unwise
impatient vineyard owner
and a much wiser patient gardener
that's that's what they're hearing right
this is where the disconnect comes in
the modern world because we're just like
i don't know what i'm listening to is
that how should i feel about this but
that's i think that's how they were
feeling we've got an unwise impatient
vineyard owner a wise impatient gardener
um
so
this brings us back to the question so
who is that vineyard owner here's what i
want to contend um i i think well let me
frame it like this who is the harshest
critic
of your life
yourself
right i think now it could be maybe
there's like some authority figure in
your life and like it's like that person
okay and that's why i'm not saying like
no it's not that you know well it could
be no that works right in the parable
but the way i want to name it for us is
i actually think because we are like in
other words if we're the if if the the
results of our life or the fig tree
um
then who's that person that's stepping
back and observing our life and is just
saying like
this is not
cutting it
right who is the who's the vineyard
owner i think it's us
like
who's the harshest critic of my life
me
god's not the vineyard owner in the
parable um i am i look at my own life
and uh i mean my goodness
what do i what do i what do we say like
there's this sense um i think in which
we just anyone kind of hit adulthood and
you just feel like
my life is not going according to plan
anyone been there i had a plan i had a
good plan
or maybe some of you are like i had no
plan but my life still isn't going
according to my non-plan uh i didn't
want to end up here wherever i am not
good
uh this right this is what we do like we
just we see the fig tree of our life and
it's just it's just not producing the
the successes
the the winds the the transformations
the changes the freedoms right it's just
like we just see we just saw ourselves
being just farther down the road
and we are
and so what do we do we
we just see our pitiful fig tree of a
life at least it's pitiful to us
and we're just like yeah this is
cut it down
burn it down dig it up
i am i am done
i'm done i'm just my life this is the
worst right and you say brett it's not
it's not for lack of trying i'm trying i
am trying but i'm just not i'm not
getting anywhere there is no there's no
good fruit in my life
or there's just a little baby you know
it's like i was just expecting more
and there if you go to our meetups you
know every the third question
always a third question and for the
meetup guide as always what what this is
what i have to write every week i don't
have to write i just copy faced what for
the spirit is god inviting you to grow
into this week and i can just imagine at
some point i'm sure someone's been quite
annoyed just like none
none of them no fruit no fruit is
happening in this like no love joy peace
patience kindness goodness gentleness
faithful to self-control none zero it's
not happening in me
right
uh a fair fair critique i think
it's i'm not offended um
because i've been there
we all have
we've all been there
okay so the fig tree that's our results
or lack thereof um we're the vineyard
donor most the time we're the venue
donor
so who's god
who's god
yeah the gardener
the caretaker
so there we are
pitching our fit
that's what i say is apparent
they're pitching a fit you know there we
are pitching a fit and we're just like
oh my gosh my life this just is not
happening for me
and just like cut it down burn it down
dig it up like it's just this is this is
the worst and then god's there saying
you know what
slow it down
give it time
give it space
that we're not done yet i'm not done
with you
yet
in fact let me get in here isn't that
what he said so let me let me fertilize
it let me get in here and dig around
and add some nutrients and like together
we're don't you worry we've got this
right now he's kind of i get the sense
that the the the caretaker the gardener
here is kind of trying to buy time
because he says like well maybe like
give it another year you know and then
if
maybe then we'll then we'll cut it you
know later like give it another 365 days
you know sort of just trying to buy time
because we're like we're done
right we're
done
i think it's uh interesting that in that
leviticus 19 um god says five years
give it five
years
i don't know about you i don't wait five
years for anything
you wait five years i don't i'm trying
to i was imagining sort of in our
culture you know our
i want it now
you know
kind of culture
and i was just thinking like i mean
what are the things like imagine someone
who's like you know i'm
i'm on the uh the five year the half a
decade weight loss plan
you know the the five year start a new
business plan
it's like what no we need six months and
even that is a little too long you know
imagining the six months to better abs
plan would never sell right no one would
ever like six months like oh my gosh
this is six minutes a day for a week
maybe i could do that you know
yeah we're just we just want it we want
it now there's a great uh
a quote
from a wonderful local pastor please
don't go to church don't leave me but he
is a wonderful pastor td jake some of
you maybe listen to him he's wonderful
but he has a line he said this said god
is thinking in terms of decades we're
praying about tomorrow
that is it
isn't that it
like i'm just freaking out about like
okay maybe this week maybe i stretch it
a little bit but not you know i mean
it's just that's where my horizon is
that's where our vision is
right and god's thinking
years
and decades in fact you might even say
generations
and not just like
i don't have kids no no i mean this is
about think of it like you're here if
you're a part of this community you are
impacting generations
all those little voices in there
there's a generational thing happening
right in your extended family and
in
workplace there's a ripple effect that's
happening
we're just like freaking out about you
know
tomorrow
so we say cut it down
what's the line verse seven why should
it use up the soil
that's a good line in other words this
this change this transformation it's
taking up too much energy
it's not happening fast enough why
should it use up the soil just i am
giving
up
because we we just we want to see
now
if i had to kind of sum up like what do
you what
what are you getting at i'd say it like
this in a um fast
food
fast fashion
fast talk
kind of culture the least hip things
imaginable
are precisely what we need
patience
faithfulness
slowness
oh that's not hip
slow i need to do things slower
well yeah because we need to do it like
well
i mean there's something in rushing
that's like i'm trying to rush the
results here i'm trying to get i'm
trying to skip the process right god has
me in a process because it's about
producing creating fruit
in my life results transformations and
that just flat out that just takes time
it just takes time
but what happens i think um
well maybe i put it like this um by
god's grace you and i can change
it just takes longer than we'd like
that's kind of where we are
there's a one of my mentors keith
spurgeon he said the the number one tool
of the enemy in my life is
discouragement
and i think that is so true
like in in essence that's kind of how
i'm reading this parable tonight i think
this is a a parable
um
not about god rejecting us although
that's kind of our knee-jerk
interpretation you know i'm the fig tree
not producing enough transformation in
my life and then god's like yeah you're
not cutting it you know so we're going
to cut you down like that's that's what
we're reading um that's i don't think
that's a good reading i think instead
actually this is about um
self-judgement and self-rejection
and why would we do that
because we're discouraged
the the transformation the change is
just not happening fast enough for us
and so we're like ah just
why should why should i use up the soil
i mean into in a really dark place you
could give a kind of suicidal reading of
that
all right really what we're kind of
saying here is like cut me down
burn me up take me out
why should i use up the soil
probably others could do better
um let me just name that as a reading
from hell
that is not god's word to you tonight
you are not just taking up soil
in this world
you are called to produce fruit and it
is happening
it is happening it's just happening
slower than you'd like
but it's happening
i had a um just to be really honest and
vulnerable with you all i had a
really a difficult um
tuesday morning i woke up two weeks ago
uh
a little under two weeks ago tuesday
morning
and um
i've struggled with uh pretty bad
anxiety my whole life i didn't know this
until i was into my early 30s
you know because you're just head spaces
your head space you just grow up with it
just as normal you know and then you
kind of realize like oh crap didn't know
um so i had very bad anxiety and i would
say mild depression never like can't get
out of bed depression but just mild but
it's it's been there
um and i have a whole you know host of
routines and
supplements and things that have really
helped me um
but uh but sometimes i have these dark
moments you know and so i wake up
tuesday morning two weeks ago
and uh if you've ever struggled with
anxiety depression you've probably had
these moments where you wake up i mean
you haven't even done anything i haven't
haven't even succeeded or failed or
anything you know i haven't done
anything i just woke up
and
this thought of my eyes open and i can
just instantly tell oh no
bad head space and the thought just
flashes through my mind brett you're
such a failure
and i was like
and just it sort of washed over me and
it was like and it was
i sort of knew what that
part of me was saying like i knew all
the areas all the things that whether
it's you know
um
i don't know there's all sorts of
accusations i make against myself when
i'm the in the vineyard owner mode oh my
gosh you know
my my kids aren't good enough i suck it
as a soccer coach
i
uh my church isn't large enough or you
know i don't know whatever
my expectations at times you know or
something
um
on and on you know just it's sort of
that it's just that sense of i want to
be there you know down the road
that's where i'm supposed to be like
25 miles you know
and so i just had this moment just
your failure watches and i now i've
lived with anxiety long enough to know
um don't lay there and ruminate
don't do that right so i'm like it's
almost like fighting through a fog i'm
just like ah so i just get out of bed
i'm like no and i start my my routines
you know
and
um and i sit down for my morning prayers
and i thought that would help but then
it didn't i sit down it's almost like
the silence it just washes over me again
just like
you know failing
and
i just felt kind of prompted that moment
like okay
i need
like the word gratitude came to mind
and so i just started drawing like
bringing to mind all of the beautiful
things from my life
you know
my children's faces my wife's face
um
my friends
many of you
you know the good things god's doing i
mean the truth is y'all i live an
insanely blessed rich wonderful life
that's like really the truth
and the truth is this community god is
blessed
i mean it's cheesy but i'll say it god's
blessed blessed our socks off
i mean really it's it's so good what
god's doing here and so many of you so
beautiful
and i just sat there and it was like
it was almost like in that moment of
that that little five minutes it was
like i lived the parable you know there
were the results or lack thereof in my
life you know and there's me the
vineyard donor judging myself and then
there's god like saying no i i wouldn't
give up yet i think god i think i'm
doing something here i see the fruit
so how about you
you know maybe it's um
maybe it's your
the state of your marriage romantic
relationship or lack thereof
and there's just a sense of like ah
we're not supposed to be here i'm not
supposed to be here
god's word to you is don't give
up
there is fruit
in your life
maybe your um
maybe something about yourself
body
health
something you would want to change
and you just feel like ah just
i'm not getting anywhere
god's word to you is
he sees you
he loves you he's not giving up on you
there's fruit in your life
maybe it's your life your career
business
that fig tree just
looking a little thin
god's word to you is don't give up
there's fruit
in your life
so table let's like let's be a church
community
where we are not
vineyard owners
to ourselves and one another
let's be good gardeners
caretakers
life
speakers
light
givers
let's be those kind of people
so as we come to
the lord's table
tonight
um
that's the posture we're coming in
we're coming to the god who is a good
gardener
not a mean vineyard owner but a good
gardener one who actually gave his very
life
his body his blood to set us free from
shame
in condemnation
and judgment
and he's inviting us to partake
and join him
in freedom
grace
forgiveness
hope
so that's what we're doing as we come
forward
we practice what's called an open table
meaning if you're here tonight and you
would like to participate
then you are welcome to do that
you say i don't know if i have all the
right beliefs or theology well
if you want to participate you come
forward
so this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith
and you who have
little you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
because it's the lord who invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
mm-hmm
so
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
me
it's the first time in is
[Music]
is
you
[Music]
is
um
why do you got to ask me to come up here
after you guys do such a great job um
and i have to try to have everything
together
i do want to say this one thing um
there is
coming to
this group this church there's many
times where i hear some music or hear a
sermon
and it's like reclaiming scripture
i don't know if you guys ever
experienced that
but in my experience just going to
different churches being involved in
different faith spaces and things like
that
there's just so many times where
scripture has just not been used well
and i come here and
i just i'm feeling more at peace i feel
more whole i feel seen
um
and it's it's a restorative situation
and so it was kind of
y'all are amazing
okay
so um
with that being said uh please don't
forget
um after this service we are doing a
state of the table a meeting we'd love
for you please stick around we are going
to be doing that um about 6 15. um we
have a quick little break between the
service the next meeting so please stick
around for that
and then also if you would please stand
i'd like to send you off
with this blessing
and if you'd like to extend your open up
your hands
to receive that as you feel
led so you
are a child of god
you
this is true in your best day
this is true in your worst day
so as you go out into your week ahead
with us yet to be determined highs and
lows
and everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you were worthy
and you were accepted
just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts of grace
and unconditional love with everyone
you come in contact with
amen
so